>>ALL RIGHT, OUR NEXT GUEST HAS
NOW BEEN CAUGHT UP IN DEMOCRAT'S
WITCH-HUNT AND IT HAS COST HIM
DEALER AND PERSONALLY, MICHAEL
CAPUTO.
HE'S HAD TO SELL HIS HOME TO PAY
FOR LEGAL FEES ASSOCIATED WITH
THE RUSSIA PROBE AND HE'S NOW
FEARFUL THAT HIS KIDS' FUTURES
ARE IN JEOPARDY OVER THIS.
THIS WEEK CAPUTO HAD HARSH
WORDS.
WHAT AMERICA NEEDS IS AN
INVESTIGATION OF THE
INVESTIGATORS.
I WANT TO KNOW WHO WITH'S
SPAYING FOR THIS?
I WANT TO KNOW WHO COST US SO
MUCH MONEY, WHO CRUSHED OUR
KIDS, FORCED US OUT OF OUR HOME
ALL BECAUSE YOU LOST AN
ELECTION.
I WANT TO KNOW BECAUSE, WELL,
G-D YOU TO HELL.
MICHAEL CAPUTO JOINS US NOW.
I KNOW YOU'RE NOT THE ONLY ONE.
YOU SAID WHAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
FEEL.
I SAID THIS TO RUDY GIULIANI THE
OTHER NIGHT.
I WATCHED FROM DAY ONE IN THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
I'M GUESSING -- I DON'T KNOW FOR
SURE.
SHE PROBABLY SPENT MORE LEGAL
FEES THAN SHE WAS PAID LAST
YEAR.
AND I THINK THAT'S THE CASE FOR
A LOT OF PEOPLE.
EXPLAIN HOW THIS IMPACTS YOU AND
YOUR FAMILY.
>> WELL, IT ALL STARTED --
WELL, THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
BUT IT ALL STARTED ON MARCH 20TH
OF 2017 WHEN THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE HAD A
PUBLIC HEARING WHERE
REPRESENTATIVE JACKIE SPEIER
BROUGHT MY AND MY WIFE'S NAME UP
IN THE HEARING AND CALLED ME
PUTIN'S IMAGE MAKER.
THE THREATS TO OUR FAMILY CAME
JUST ONE AFTER THE OTHER.
DEATH THREAT AFTER DEATH THREAT.
ONE GUY CALLED ME AFTER THAT
HEARING ON THE PHONE AND SAID,
"I KNOW YOU'RE NOT HOME.
WE'RE GOING TO BURN YOUR HOUSE
DOWN WITH YOUR WIFE AND CHILDREN
INSIDE."
THESE THREATS HAVEN'T STOPPED.
I HAD TO LAWYER UP WHEN IT
BECAME CLEAR I WAS GOING TO BE
PULLED INTO THE CONGRESSIONAL
INVESTIGATIONS.
AND SINCE THEN, AFTER A
COMMITTEE INTELLIGENCE HEARING
IN 2017 AND THEN A SENATE
COMMITTEE HEARING ON TUESDAY AND
NOW SITTING BEFORE THE MUELLER
TEAM ON WEDNESDAY, WE'RE AT
ABOUT $125,000.
I WANT TO TELL YOU, WE WERE ON
OUR WAY OUT OF OUR HOME, SEAN,
ON OUR WAY OUT BECAUSE WE
COULDN'T HAVE A HOME LIKE WE HAD
AND MAKE BUFFALO MONEY.
WE HAD TO MOVE TO WASHINGTON TO
MAKE WASHINGTON MONEY SO I COULD
PAY THE DEBT THAT I HAD -- THESE
$125,000 IS MORE THAN I MAKE IN
A YEAR HERE IN EAST  AURORA, NEW
YORK.
WE DON'T MAKE THAT MUCH OUT
HERE.